love is blind is the craziest show on
Netflix and this is coming from a guy
who's watched every episode of the
island my god Brad this is a show that
just needs to be seen to be believed and
yes the puns get worse as the video goes
along in this video we're gonna take a
deep dive into romance and answer the
question everyone's been asking is love
blind oh we're gonna get into that piece
of work and who better to explain the
show than Nick Lachey and his wife
Vanessa because if there's anyone who
knows anything about love it's this guy
Donna to see if love is actually blonde
contestants spend the next week engaging
in dates in these rooms called pods
without actually seeing their partner
only if and when a proposal is accepted
will the couples be able to see each
other move in and get married yes the
experiment gets off to a great start
with contestants immediately making
connections and who can forget most of
these contestants we literally only see
once and never again so what are you
looking for in a woman in shape and
beautiful sound shallow at all if I had
to guess I'd say you're african-american
I hate I hate I hate being able to hear
people breathe the first episode is
filled with people we only see once and
then they just kind of disappear so
tinfoil hat theory I honestly think some
of these contestants are plants like
take for example Rory over here remember
this guy we never see him talking to any
of the girls he only gives emotional pep
talks to the other guys deep breath in
sorry if he'll tell you you tell her
what's going on break down be emotional
and give it everything you've got scary
right it's something that's powerful
force the air out I also like how
everyone on the show is given the most
generic job titles Lexi sales manager
Jessica regional manager damien general
manager and cameron scientists within
the first few days couples form with
cameron and lauren being the first to
say their i love yous keep in mind this
happens thirty minutes into the first
episode and pretty soon the
puzzles begin to fly I want to ask you
will you marry me
hello for those of you don't know this
is mark and Jessica who agreed to an
engagement even though they're 10 years
apart which for Jessica isn't a big deal
at all right he is the most special
person I've ever met and age is not a
factor for us right
we're so disciplined I mean we're 10
years apart I will I'm going to be open
and honest with you okay you're 10 years
younger than I when you're a 24 year old
woman and you're 34 old woman that's two
differently jessica is a piece of work
not only does she feed her dog wine yes
that actually happened but she gets
upset at one of the dudes for not
knowing what he wants and then proceeds
to tag mark a guy she doesn't like at
all
all the way to the altar only to dump
him this girl literally has a breakdown
while putting on her wedding dress
she's such a mess that just a day later
after questioning her relationship with
Mark she says stuff like this now I have
to bring up that the way the show
depicted her it seems like she really
has a drinking problem
the red flag with the exception of a few
scenes she's almost always holding a
giant glass of wine and unlike shows
like The Bachelor where it's rare to see
the women get blackout sloppy drunk love
is blind does not shy away
I saw you baby I know yes if you were to
ever to actively go after my husband the
drinking is so out of control on the
show that in multiple dates that
contestants have to drink out of these
aluminum cups because they'd been
smashing too many glasses by episode
three six couples emerge for the next
phase Cameron and Lauren Jeana and
Damian amber and Barnett Kelly and Kenny
mark and Jessica and Carlton and diamond
the next phase of the show I call the
honeymoon phase even though they're not
married yet which sees if the couples
can translate their emotional love into
the physical and Nick and Vanessa arrive
once again to collect their paychecks
seriously their screen time the entire
season is shorter than NICs marriage
with Jessica Simpson uncalled-for while
in Mexico the couples really get to find
out more about each other and the pair
that really struggle with this are
Carlton and diamonds meet Carlton no not
that one who is the son of a preacher he
made daddy feel good weave walking down
I'm gonna get you a pogo stick so you
can hop out of your feelings right now
whatever Carlton has failed to tell
Diamond something you should probably
tell your fiance he's also into men and
while things don't end well for Carlton
and diamond Damien isn't quite
interpreting Giannina signals I won't
move at your pace the sex is not
important it's looking pretty romantic
in there I'm just telling you it's been
435 days I went to the beach so I could
remember how it feels to have my aspect
but I'm just hope for the love of God
Damien meanwhile Jessica struggles to
come to terms with the fact the voice
she fell in love with is attached to
someone she's clearly not physically
attracted to which is pretty funny since
her voice does this weird baby thing I
love hearing the waves where have I
heard this before
I love cheese and while paradise may be
working out for some it appropriate to
put it in a prenup that you want sex
every day things come to a head in the
final confrontation between Carlton and
diamond I love you I love you too
oh oh oh sorry wrong clip that's why I
don't deal with [ __ ] like you watch
your wig does it keep slack I just can't
believe it didn't work out between those
two I also want to take a moment to
highlight a few things I just found
unromantic about the show like how some
of the outdoor dates are so poorly lit
it looks like I'm watching a home video
or the fake actors they sometimes have
eating in the background oh wait they
don't even have meals and as the
honeymoon portion of the show reaches
its end things are still rocky for mark
and Jessica I'm being patient but
everyone else is having sex and it sucks
yes old blue balls here is frustrated
that Jessica isn't putting out but who
can blame her when she's constantly
talking [ __ ] behind his back the way I
feel when I'm around mark is not the way
I want to feel around my fiance when he
kisses me it doesn't feel right or
comfortable not to mention she often
takes off her ring and that's because
she's still super attracted to Barnett
who she made a connection with in the
pods just to put things into perspective
how Jessica just does not care about
this relationship she shows up to her
romantic date in a gray tee and her hair
in a bun like this is what you'd wear
when you're home alone watching a
romantic comedy with a tub of Ben and
Jerry's with some relationships blooming
and others of flaming trainwreck the
couples move on to the next phase of the
show where they have to live together in
the real world and with 20 days until
the wedding things start to get even
more serious Barnett finds out Amber's
in terrible debt and janilla is pissed
at Damien's listening skills I have been
listening mother [ __ ]
for two seconds I have listened to you
since the day we hold on is that just
good just chilling in the back eating
some chicken and she's an absolute mess
like just look at her like a rag doll
and if things couldn't get worse for
mark after the party ends jessica says
this to him
I think Barnett is [ __ ] sexy and like
hot and like even the dog isn't having
any of it the next episode deals with a
couples meeting the families which is
just filled with some absolute gems like
Jessica trying to give wine to Mark's
underaged nephew or Giannina not being
satisfied in bed you know how you told
me this is the best sex of your life
have you noticed that I don't return the
compliment you do not just say that I
also noticed this weird thing and I'm
not sure if the producers did this that
a lot of the times when the couple's
talk they're talking in separate rooms
not able to see each other
almost as if they're trying to recreate
that scenario they had in the pods one
of the more interesting meetings is that
between Cameron and Lauren's parents
since Cameron is a bit anxious how
they'll feel about their daughter
marrying a white boy and what better way
to relate to your future
african-american mother-in-law then by
rapping last off the course is like a
crash collision because every choice we
make is like a rash decision but the
truth is yep that just happened with
only eight days before the wedding
tensions mount like Giannina gets pissed
at little things like Damien checking
his phone well later that night she does
the exact same thing when Damien is in
the middle of a heartfelt conversation
and since we've gotten back
like seriously oh and we have to talk
about the bachelor and bachelorette
parties first of all the girls get a
stripper a drag queen show and a venue
with enough disco balls to induce
everyone to seizures what do the guys
get in art gallery needless to say it's
an absolute [ __ ] show with Jessica in
top form but the second last episode
ends with a big cliffhanger our first
wedding now I gotta say this is
absolutely batshit insane each of the
couples have to decide whether or not to
go through with marriage in front of
their families leaving those who get
dumped humiliated in front of their
friends and family and just look at
Damian when he's asked if he wants to
marry Giannina it's like he's taking a
big dump which is exactly what he does
choosing not to go ahead with marriage
and if things couldn't get any worse for
Giannina Damian proceeds to tell her
entire family why things didn't work
well she runs away and falls on her ass
Giannina wants some answers saying I
always treated you with kindness let's
roll the tape mother [ __ ] listen have
you noticed that I don't return the
compliment kelly also smashes Kenny's
marriage hopes when she says she can't
go through with it and just check out
Kelly's mom she's like ooh I also don't
know why Jessica and Mark any way better
wedding venue especially since shocker
jessica says she can't go through with
it and her post interview is pretty
savage and I guess I'll apologize to
whoever I need to apologize to but I'm
not gonna apologize to myself because
I'm not actually sorry I guess she's
gonna go back to drinking with her dog
the show does however have a happy
ending for two couples amber and Barnet
and Lauren and Cameron both of whom I
believe are still together
so did we learn anything through this 10
episode journey of love is love really
blind well I certainly am after watching
this show I'm kidding I actually thought
this was premium trash TV and I hope
this comes back for season 2 and they'll
work out some of the kinks and hopefully
tighten the pacing of some of the
episodes because some of them were just
way too long now I also want to give a
shout out to an amazing channel that you
have to subscribe to if you like dating
shows or reality
TV bachelor fan take this guy's theories
and breakdowns are top-notch so be sure
to check them out I've left a link in
the description also stay tuned March
5th as the love is blind reunion will be
dropping on Netflix I'm not sure if I'll
be doing a video on it but we'll see I
hope you guys enjoyed the video it's a
little different than my normal one so
let me know what you thought about it in
the comments below and make sure to give
the video a like you can also follow me
on twitter at big story whitey until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much